[Music]  earlier this week Joe Biden was asked if  he was planning to run for president and  he had this to say there may be reasons  I don't run but there's no obvious  reason for me why I think I should not  run  well that statement set the tone for  Biden's first presidential campaign ad  which was released online just a few  hours ago check it out Joe Biden has  served this country for over 40 years so  when he says he's not uninterested in  seeking the presidency it shouldn't be a  no-brainer to refuse to disbelieve him  body won't just not undermine the  economy he would oppose reversing all  efforts to negate unemployment he's on  the record is coming out against not  blocking anti progressive legislation  that doesn't not destabilize working  segments Joe Biden no compelling reason  not to vote for the opposite of his  opponent I'm Joe Biden and I do not  fully and especially not partially  endorse this message  you